Thank you.
Okay.
Good morning, everyone will be opening the hearing on.
144, if you want to please join me in saying the pledge allegiance to the flag.
Allegiance to the flag of the United States of America.
and to the Republic of which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
All right.
Well, currently we have nobody here to testify, apparently, from the audience.
Who would like to start the discussion?
Anyone?
All right, in that case, oh, Amanda.
Can I make a motion?
Do you feel like I'm jumping the gun if i yeah i might want to just go around get some discussion before oh i just thought no one had anything to say but because i'm ready to move on to motion whenever i don't have anything to say representative Thank you.
Turn on your mics.
If the sponsor was here, I would get clarification, but.
It's not so.
Representative Jammeron?
Anything?
Representative Gafford?
Um.
.
but he is not.
So.
William Moore, Representative Jammeron?
William Moore, Representative Gaffer?
Representative Gaffer?
I believe that there are ways that you can get your right to carry again, particularly if it is not a violent crime.
It might be a process, a long process in some cases, but there is a process in place.
So I would recommend that the prime sponsor, if they wish to actually pursue something like that, take a look at the sentencing and how long it takes to remove the felony so that they could carry arms again.
But on the same token, as a consumer and as a Nashuaite, I guess, or a New Hampshireite, I don't believe if you're a felon that you should be able to carry a gun that's my personal belief thank you and just to clarify I think you're looking for the word annulment which is a current process in New Hampshire yes when all the criminal offense whether it be misdemeanor or acceptable felony level offense uh when looking at this bill I look at it as more of an enrollment issue than i do an issue of restricting the felons currently and misdemeanors uh one of the issues that we do have is the state courts obviously have no authority over federal courts which would still be problematic for the intent i think of this bill in addition i believe that going forward hopefully we can get a better bill that does address streamlining the annulment process, which currently is the only process to restore either misdemeanor or felony rights if it's a qualifying misdemeanor.
And that stipulates a certain time frame that we may want to look at as legislators if someone so chooses to file a bill.
At this point, i would entertain any motions um i'd like to make a motion of itl there's a second motion to itl representative uh bolden Motion to ITL.
Representative Bolden?
Yes.
Representative Jammeron?
Representative Tenzar?
Yes.
Representative Gathright?
Representative?
Yes.
Thank you.
And I'm a a yes and that concludes the hearing on 144 fm that's bradley that's what happens when you don't see each other for a while you know well thank you everyone knows that oh goodness so so i guess now we've got a short recess oh yeah yeah okay Thank you.
This subcommittee work session on House Bill 512, FN.
It's a bill exempting firearms manufactured in New Hampshire from federal laws and regulations.
We have anybody to testify.
I don't have any blue cards.
All right, members of the committee.
Members of the committee All right seen nobody's has any I did want to mention that.
Soon after we heard this in committee and.
Move to retain it, I had the opportunity to go to the 6, our academy as a student.
I paid.
i think it was $25 for the class.
Very, very intuitive class on silencers, or some people would call noise suppressors.
Learned many things.
One of which, the person that made the first suppressor was also a ham radio operator.
And guess what?
I'm a ham radio operator.
One of the things that happened in the class we had some time to for questions and answers because they were talking about regulatory problems that they have um and the laws surrounding them is that um sig sour at least um that's a new hampshire manufacturer of firearm parts and firearms is.
Is fine with this bill passing, but they would never.
Offer to a New Hampshire resident any farm.
Firearm or accessories without going through the federal process, realizing that the whole purpose of this, this bill was to take into effect the 10th amendment to the United States Constitution saying that the state anything not delegated to the federal Congress remains is retained by the states.
It's retained by the states because it's not an interstate commerce.
commerce the problem being is that most of these manufacturers do engage in interstate commerce sigsauer ruger a lot of the other smaller companies here in new hampshire and we have several firearm manufacturers in new hampshire and the problem becomes if they try to sell something to a new hampshire resident exempting the laws, they put their federal firearms license or manufacturing license in jeopardy.
And as you know, Sig Sauer is the main manufacturer of firearms for the United States military.
And again, even if this bill were to pass, they would not offer anything to a New Hampshire citizen without going through the federal process that being said I don't know if anybody else has any other comments but that's pretty much the what I got out of that class that I went to it was a four-hour course very very intuitive even if you're not a firearms enthusiast it's a really good class to talk about the history the regulation and all those other things and how it works we got a chance to go and shoot suppressed fire it was really nice i have a question oh where did you take that uh it was at the sigsar academy in epping they offer it i believe quarterly it's um trying to remember the name of the class it was the fire it was was something to do with silence, Sancer Co, which is the company that also manufacturers them worked in concert with them to give that and that actually is open to the general public.
It was probably 40 people in the class.
Thank you.
So it sounds like, from what I've heard that the manufacturing side of things find this to be possibly problematic with the current language that was drafted.
That's correct.
Actually, one of the questions I had asked was, I believe Texas passed a very similar law about six, seven years ago, and they found that the manufacturers down there were offering items for sale to the general public in texas and the federal government came in and said you're a federal licensee and we will suspend your your federal license if you don't adhere to federal guidelines um well that's overreacher that's a that's for a court decide.
But if we pass this and one of the manufacturers did offer for sale to New Hampshire resident, they're putting their federal permits and licenses in jeopardy.
So I look at it as an issue where I support the general premise of this language for this bill, but I don't understand if it's ready for prime time just yet.
I think a lot more research needs to go into it to make sure that the manufacturing side is protected since all fire manufacturers in New Hampshire are only regulated by the United States federal government, not by any state entities.
I concur with Representative Stone on that.
Anybody like to make a motion?
I make a motion to ITL.
Second.
Thank you.
That's why I like our name tags on the tables.
It's too easy once we made in seconded to recommend to the full committee.
Around the table.
Yes.
Yeah, yes, yes.
I concur.
Yes, yes.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, I concur.
Yes, yes.
I have no other work before us.
Are you adjourned?
Thank you.
you many meeting on house Bill 344FN.
So I'd like to ask the committee, does anybody have anything they want to say?
Well, maybe I should.
Oh, I'm sorry.
One of the.
all right so i like to pull the committee would you guys have anything you want to say about this particular bill anyone Yes.
Thank you.
I just, I spoke with 1 of the co sponsors.
Who informed me, Representative Thomas that she does not support the bill.
She's not sure how her name is on it.
Whether that whether something was, but, but I know at this point, she does not support the bill and had some concerns about, um.
Regarding the amount from 2 to 4 ounces, she suggested that would keep it in line with legalization amounts that.
There were some protections and guidelines missing from this bill.
She was unsure of the focus on hashish and thought that maybe that the legislation start with therapeutic patients first, then move forward to the general population.
That was just the input that I got from one of the co-sponsors.
Thank you.
She did send me an email expressing the same information, actually.
But she did mention that she had another bill coming through.
Yes.
Thank you.
I do support the legalization of marijuana.
However, I think the language in this bill falls short of something that we can responsibly send forward.
And looking at it, we are in New Hampshire, which is a state surrounded by other states currently that allow marijuana possession and also sales.
I think there's more comprehensive legislation that's been introduced that's still floating around out there that would better serve our purposes and moving forward thank you yes thank you so I just have a concern there's no provision in here for people who live in apartment buildings and my concern too is that if you are giving people marijuana that you grew at home what it could be, you know, increased fentanyl risk.
I think that that's a concern too is what's in it.
I am not a proponent of legalizing marijuana, but my constituents, there's a strong push for that.
So I'd be willing to look at homegrown as long as there was, you know, some strict guidelines as far as living in multiple families, how to protect kids and address the bed.
I don't know if that's possible, but any contamination risk.
Thank you.
That was my main concern as well.
I'm not, you know, one that believes in legalizing cannabis at all.
Honestly, Thank you.
That was my main concern as well.
I'm not, you know, one that believes in legalizing cannabis at all, honestly.
But I do believe that given across New Hampshire, we're building, putting up all these apartment buildings.
And here it states that you can have six per person, over 21, 21 and over.
and I can't imagine we're just putting up a 400 unit 400 people unit in Nashua I can't even imagine that where the adults let's say if it's two adults in each house and 12 plants there 12 plants in each one of those I cannot ever imagine something like And I, you know, and not only that, just, just think about it with the children involved, okay, because they're low income and market rate housing that we're putting up.
And I don't know, I just can't comprehend it.
It won't sink in for me, but it is a concern about the health, the health and well-being of others as well, and children in particular.
And that's pretty much what I have to say.
Yes.
Just to follow up with that concern, one of the things I looked at was if this bill was to move forward, we'd be looking at some landlord-tenant issued rights that come up.
that as you've mentioned subsidized housing especially federally uh projects could jeopardize their housing situations by allowing something that would be authorized and legal in the state of new hampshire but the federal agencies do not acknowledge as being legal so i think there's a lot more work that needs to be done before this bill would move forward yes so do i have a motion medical merit but this doesn't address this is just personal for recreation right okay then yeah that's fine so you want to um okay so we have a motion on the second okay so we have a motion on the floor to itl and i will start with the site your vote yes yes yes yes yes yes in anisa vote six to zero for itl on hb 344 thank you um if no further comments then we will adjourn Thank you.
If no further comments, then we will adjourn.
Thank you.
My goodness.
That's why I said.
Thank you.